you
just under 10 seconds this is an hourly
super blitz arena a cool group of 25 for
this event more I imagine will join 3o
time control 57 minutes D 7 minute
tournament my opponent is throwing i
smith more gambit at me so let's try d5
i don't play this so much let's play e6
and where to go my queen once knight
here is played
what do i have to go anywhere um I think
I'm alright with coming all the way back
thank all their squares she's a bit
vulnerable and so we're just going to
look to play against this guy
so let's see Bishop probably on e7 I'll
look to play b6 Bishop b7 let's not do
that too soon
I want to weaken these squares let's get
castled first so I'm not subjected to
this check or even Queen a4 acknow is a
fine time for this maybe even here this
would be a desirable exchange but I am
inconvenient some maybe not as my knight
is maybe stepping in the direction of d5
at the same time this could be annoying
here Bishop takes Knight takes Knight e5
looking at knight c6
oh yeah that's a little bit concerning
to me so let's go here
I'm Bishop a6 immediately I think there
was even knight c6 possibility so this
is the most disruptive Knight disruptive
piece is the knight in my position this
is a poison pawn I'm looking at knight
c6 which would force either the knight
to go back or Knight exchange as I would
then be threatening to win the the d4
pawn I have their Queen under control my
minor pieces watch over that let's just
go here maybe even look for Knight B 4
into d 5 interesting okay I will grab
that and I'm going to go here okay I
like my
position this is now up as a color
bishops and my bishop should be pretty
good here okay
didn't expect that move
well huh alright let's think this one
through some I have some time here I
have a have a bit of a time edge now if
I go for this
this was my knee-jerk reaction rook to
d8 this is a bit uncomfortable multiple
pins I think this might be my moment to
take here Bishop takes b6 bit of a bug
well I'm still going to owe their x'
also Queen a4 striking in my bishop hmm
well it's going to get a little messy
but I'm going to do it it won't get
messy if Knight takes here but I think
messy starts with that and that's what
they go for
okay I'm going to do this anticipating
Bishop here I want to play Knight e4
believe white is better now also I need
to be prepared to play this move to
blunt this diagonal I don't have a dark
square Bishop around I have to take
extra care of my dark squares there
under a minute I have pressure on b2 but
that's probably something poison Bishop
is there to watch over and this guy is
just doing absolutely nothing I don't
know about that if they don't have
anything right away I might actually
start to like my position with the
bishop being glued on d3
although Queen here is going to pick up
the pawn yeah so I'm going to be
dropping this but no not necessarily oh
it's a bit ugly to do f5 because then my
Queen has to be the one who defends g7
but I'm going to try it in order to save
my e4 pawn
is a bit debatable the more conservative
is uh is definitely hmm oh well I also
have to move fast to let's go here I'm
going to have my rook be the one devoted
to defending g7 I need to free up my
queen let's hit the bishop about a
10-second edge let's actually go here my
bishop needs to reposition out here for
a queen exchange and can we get that I
have a queen exchange now I think I'm
better yes let's reinforce this they're
looking to undermine that so I'll need
to reinforce this guy yeah now this is
winning material and we have a connected
past pawn I could take him I have a
tough time tracking that pond down and
just go here
and the king is cut off and they
resigned yeah as mentioned hmm I could
have played a conservative just playing
f6 give up the pawn but at least be
assured that that Bishop wouldn't have
as much as say in that position but okay
there was just a quick site update
that's why there was some delay there
actually that's why we gained some time
just then okay okay so I'm stripping
white of the defense the e5 and I get to
develop what stuff oh this is nice let's
go here and I'm threatening to pick up
the bishop pair next with a six yeah now
Bishop back I have b5 and then I get the
Queen
so this is I feel like this is already
good for me and I'm looking for a way to
try to punish white and I think I could
with night b4 and I'm looking at this
hole at d3 which I believe I will get to
my Knights defended looking at night D 3
or even night C 2 so they can't just
simply Castle Knight C 2 so at the very
least have this move and I don't see a
reason not to go straight in for that
yeah let's do that they are now
uncounseled let's go here defend c4
let's also think about Bishop b4 try
with Bishop b4 now I may want to go to
be for to give check on c2 if the King
goes in this direction so I'm just
looking a complete development I
shouldn't be looking for anything fancy
here I could also take on f2 actually
yeah I know I'm going to grab another
pond I should have done that sooner I
have this mode or I could even return
here let's as I said let's complete
development I'm up to pawns now and
let's go here strike at the rook get out
of the pin soon they could attack my
knight I think this is a fine spot for
my king I'm going to try to undermine it
they are ok but you know what oh my
goodness I could go for another pun
doing it
King takes I get to take here and now
this is a beautiful spot for my knight
who basically negates the bishop
opposite color bishops this is too much
material there down too much material
right am i talking up is color bishops
dude
you got dark square bishop sideboard
okay we're just going to take I really
would rather not help them develop where
else is that night going to go that's
bothering me no let's not help them
develop stake with the rook I'm
controlling this pawn break and now I'm
just looking at stuff like this yeah
welcome to all sorts of exchanges note
on rook here
I shouldn't capture because rook here
and if I take the bishop I get skewered
so my idea would have been to just take
the bishop had rook c1 been played I
think I could get away with just saving
that pond no let's just finish
development yeah I could give back some
material even
another poem try that okay now let's
scoop him up King f6 51 seconds rook
here is offset with rook a4 even if I
drop these two pawns let's insert a
check I don't know here
okay fate and
some exchanges one rook it's a
completely winning this two rooks I
don't think I'll be allowing any counter
play here alright let's just slowly
start pushing these guys my only
sensitive point is really f7 but I have
it covered looking at this next I'd be
fine with giving up two pawns just to
get the rooks off and that's what's
going to happen I imagine so he's going
to get that guy but it's four versus two
and these guys are split it shouldn't be
too difficult to convert 31 seconds
should be plenty get my king here and
then even maybe do something like this
now I'm a bit I'm be fearful of a some
stalemates let's do this and push my
rook is here cutting guarding that
square there's stalemate ideas for my
King here
maybe then rookie too and then look for
mate with this move also okay
17 seconds
you
the best I'm going to put my rook on h1
I think I'm winning this pawn now King
here I have check and then check and
then I pick up the pawn with I'll not
with check but now I'm up three here and
then look up for mate soon
ten seconds seven seconds watch out for
stalemates rook here next there's
probably something easier there huh five
seconds
plenty of time and there we go hmm very
time-consuming game but in the end and
got the W okay we have 43 minutes in
change
56 players now okay so clearly many more
entered this one the virtual on board
let's try efore yeah that game my
opponent
gaming one too many pawns let's try the
advanced and let's go with these modest
kingside minor peace deployments and
hold off on committing my C pawn just
yet
maybe c4 maybe c3
hmm I'm going to go with c4 now trying
to show that the Queen on c7 is a bit
too early wow that is a big decision
see file is ripped open and these two
are on the same there they're on the C
file this should be winning by force I
have a lead in development this pawn
makes it awkward for these guys to get
out and about and I'm already looking at
rook c1 with Knight discoveries I think
this has to be attempted it's not so
this is probably just busted now Knight
takes here or is there something better
I'm going to take here and then take
here winning a piece don't know if that
was the best move order should be good
enough that was a very big decision to
Castle queenside
I guess we're going to take with the
Queen and go here which is threatening
this push discover check winning more
material let's get on this open file I
don't want to help black develop maybe
now I do they had to work for it though
you know if I'm backing up there's g5 I
don't think I have a future with my
Queen there my knight needs to
reposition he's a dummy black should
find it difficult to stay coordinated
let's just keep the knight out of c4 and
let's do this if they take I get the d4
square for my knight it'll go from being
my worst piece to maybe my best piece
think we're having that happen right now
also knight on d4 looks to get rid of
this bishop let's just mmm
also go with b5 let's just secure here
they take they run into some pin it
might be alright um actually I'm going
to do this
I don't think after f6 that would have
really net me much what I'm going to do
is try to get rid of their glue and
their glue is their Bishop as soon as
he's out well this was a passed pawn as
soon as he's gone now they have to watch
out for all sorts of things Bishop takes
pawn
what about push or no let's let's keep
the structure as is I have a flight
square on f2 for my king we're going to
stay active with the Queen just a no
actually there's not even a single check
I'm threatening Bishop takes Knight now
this is probably too much to deal with
Bishop takes Knight
could insert this check first and
probably just smash through yeah
taking the pawns all with check there
shouldn't be any fortress here let's
give another check I'd like to take here
with check got that
and what pawn to push don't think it
matters too much 48 seconds time is my
biggest concern ideally I'd like to move
these guys on light squares but should
be okay now let's move forward nothing
wrong with that it's in sir to check now
let's just continue to push check and
then push no fancy skewers or anything
let's go here and then push through and
that should do it
b8 next they're going to play on some
now they resign
okay yeah that was too quick a decision
to go Queen side there I think better
was to take on c4 and then try to
operate on the d5 square 97 to d5 okay
first time I'm playing this opponent
let's try the Dutch stuff for some
variety yeah you know and I played this
in the similar as one of the games I
lost on time because of though site
being down for just a bit okay well one
thing I like about the bishop being here
I could say is that taking advantage of
e6 with the knight is a bit harder to
get in I'd like to get e5 in in one shot
not easily accomplished let's see what
they do about that actually are they
going to play here otherwise getting an
e5 I think is very nice in one shot so
they didn't do anything about that I am
in a pin but I don't think it's
something that should be too much of
inconvenience I think I could resolve it
pretty quick 95c 6 on pawn takes pawn I
think I'm going to be taking with the
pawn maybe this was too early I wonder
if it's important to for me to have
first played c6 I'm not
or at the very least I'm playing quick
and my opponent is already at the
two-minute mark if they Castle I could
already consider pushing this night
we'll have to find a new square and I
could look to maybe try for f4 okay so
I'm pretty sure Knight takes Knight
takes pawn takes Queen takes being on
castled in short I don't think I could I
don't think that's a wise choice for me
so I'm looking at c6 right now I think
that's a good idea it may turn out that
this Knight is simply out of play
i weakened d6 for the moment the Queen
could try to make use of that Eve 5 I'm
going to close it up with that last move
they've weakened d4 this is now a whole
I'd like to have dark square bishop Soph
the board and a knight planted on d4 so
it comes to mind is a light square
bishop for Knight exchange and one day
ending up with a knight on d4 that's you
just can't get rid of them this was
maybe too quick a decision
I want the Queen's off got them and soon
they're gonna have to give this guy up
otherwise I'm trapping the bishop let's
get this move in they're going to give
up the c5 square no they held ground on
that alright I got to take with the
bishop to keep this covered and now my
knight as soon as he's on f8 I have this
idea in mind okay
this is the right way forward I don't
think I'm in a position to have the a
file open up so that's why I think I do
well to keep the tension at the same
time this might be an idea they gave up
control of this square so this might be
my time to pounce on d4 on Knight b3 I
could do this let's do that I think I
only need one moment on this square for
him to be disruptive they may try to
challenge him right away but I could
maybe be a pest with night be three I
might actually be quite close to getting
exactly what I want which is a bishop
for night exchange and a knight on d4 my
concern is that on Knight be three
there's rook here threatening Knight
takes pawn rook takes rook takes well
I'm going to hold off because of that
tactic I'm going to hold off on Knight
be three because of this stuff and slow
play at Sun let's get one rook exchanged
maybe get my bishop on f2 pointing at c4
and then my knight back here this is a
really good square so if my Knights on
e6 and their night is on f3 I kind of
view that as you know they're in a more
restricted position they have to play
the role of defense so they have to get
back here controlling d4 Bishop g4 now
they're allowing me to get in here and
now things are now different because I
could rely upon this square my bishop is
there too to defend so let's go here Oh
rook here hmm should I really be
concerned about that probably I don't
think that that rook is so much a bother
hmm all right change of plans that guy
is just too much of a pest let's go here
defend the pawn and now I don't have
anything though I didn't play that well
in fact I think white is just better now
bishop here and then I'm going to soon
lose this pawn
let's also watch out for the time here I
shouldn't have done that
I think it allowed me to fix one of
their ponds they shouldn't have allowed
that move okay yep I played that well
that could have very easily gone wrong
for them so they did a very good job
just then playing very fast they're down
on time hmm I couldn't quite pull it off
what I wanted to have happen maybe I
missed something along the way with that
earlier night b3 move and rook b1 I just
didn't see a good way to follow up and
be able to maintain my night on b3
because of that sack on a4 stripping my
knight of Defense on b3 yeah
they I think they defended well there
from many many of my positional threats
okay let's look for a essential
expansion but before I do that let's
insert h3 I like this move to rule out
any Bishop g4 stuff let's tuck him all
the way back this was another game that
I had in the Simon that I was not able
to finish and I think in that game he
was dropped in here which stays out of
Knight c4 with tempo against my bishop
what this may mean is that I could allow
the knight to sit there for just a bit
oh I didn't see that move but in the end
I think they're going to end up with a
target on d6 he's weak how do they get
rid of him
probably a good follow-up is here and
just get my last piece working Brooke a
to d1 preparing to play d5 and eliminate
this guy Bishop f2 he's vulnerable there
hmm yeah I think I think I'll be ready
for some tactical sequence let's try
this I'm preparing to sacrifice on f2
some captures here and then a knight
here also a knight on d6 would hit the
whole farm that may be close to
happening very close actually Bishop
takes Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen
takes Knight takes pawn hitting the
Queen and threatening Knight d6 hitting
everything that may just happen let's
see take their first here next and then
on Queen takes Knight takes Bishop
hitting the Queen and then incoming
Knight d6 I also have this so I'm not
down any material I just kind of saw it
as initially at least I saw it as you
know their King is exposed the positions
open and they're still saddled with this
guy here what am I missing
I understand why they I guess because I
was going to do this so now just up the
exchange I don't think there's a reason
to insert Queen d5 maybe there is no she
has a responsibility here
I'd like a different flight square for
my King this could be a strong post
maybe I should have f4 in mind
two points of attack right now let's go
in for this if they want to take care
I'll get to the seventh this keeps their
Bishop at bay Bishop here probably get
out of the pins so I could get enough
for
this bishop c3 although I have this
check can I just
just get some kind of mate though going
on now they have this covered enough um
let's start with g3 now they're covering
that let's do this bishop c3 I have
Queen check a bit a level say on the
clocks Queen d5 Queen f4 many different
ways to be getting at the King could
easily uh what is that story with that
just take the pawn with Chuck don't
understand that one hmm okay well I
could even look to invest some material
back get some material back maybe take
the bishop here and they just resigned
you know I might have had rook takes and
then here winning the rook on c7 hmm I
think that that was a good decision by
me to play Bishop c4 although maybe
instead of taking on e4 with their
Bishop they could have considered d5
straightaway mmm not a hundred percent
on that clearly how are we doing in the
standings 2017 I'm at sixteen
okay let's try b4 no a 300 game okay
let's get them here
III see for now let's go straight in for
that no rapid development I like it
and a three
yeah I don't want to do this I'm bit
concerned at the a six move my knight
knows where he belongs by King night my
King knows where he belongs my queen
Knight not sure let's do this first
throw a pawn in the center he's a very
flexible piece on D - yeah I like that
Knight on D - rook on c1 I have c3
covered rook see one night here I'm
threatening this move now let's get by
rook here a knight on c5 would be nice
Queen on b3 Queen on b3 might run into
a5 and on b5 there's a five um let's get
a flight square not quite sure how to
play it I come all the way back I may
want to play here this is a strong piece
probably their best piece and I know I
could try to
oh that my LightSquared bishop is better
than theirs being on this diagonal but I
don't know how would they reply if I go
straight in for a night on c5 especially
now that the bishop isn't there to take
them out striking at this heart all
sorts of tactics now maybe even here as
well like takes pawn is here Knight
takes pawn here as well
counter sacrifice on b4 though I want to
win some material if I'm going to do
that
let's continue to develop Queeny to rip
d1 stay stay ahead on the clock here
this is a different scenario though and
it take now night takes here Oh actually
I had that previously because there
wasn't a counter sacrifice on before I
could be taking here I'm on c7 and I
missing that so I get this pawn up to
pawns no and all this just started just
from having some pressure here just
having a knight on c5 is just a monster
141 still good level of two pawns
okay
I could revisit try to revisit that
square yeah let's actually try with the
rook pretty active piece let's double
here it's the only open file okay you
know I want to just get rid of one of
their best pieces let's do this my rook
is in convenience on the recapture but
trades nearly all trade should be
favoring me here b3 I'll go to c2 not
tactically vulnerable I have defense
here and I'm going to spot to double up
let's just go here see if they invite my
queen forward she
very active piece on b5 there is no pin
they are insisting on a trade I don't
think that their night on a7 is a good
piece I'd rather exchange have this
exchange occur night for night maybe
even 94
my night controls their bishop I think I
want to play within the structure I
don't think it's necessary to even start
pushing like this giving up squares
giving blacks some targets steak with
the rook I'm also in the spot to play
Queen c2 Knight b5 is a move um
let's step up here now I don't even want
to allow Knight d6 with tempo maybe now
I do this actually I don't want to allow
94 Knight f5 I'm threatening this fork
okay now I get to jump into these
squares knight c6 incoming this is a
hole I have support for it maybe with b5
or d5 my queen is attacked but in the
end my knight on c6 is enormous saving
everything defending everything let's
kick the night away and where's the win
take the bishop and enter I don't have
any time either let's just make sure the
knight stays dead he's going nowhere
he's still going nowhere
the knight has to go to the corner to
defend it's no good
yeah just centralize the king Bishop d6
and night here the bishop goes here and
they're offset they are down on time
okay he had the night on c5 turned out
to be a giant pest 20 minutes 50 seconds
top is 24 20 20 next I'm at 20 with fire
89 players in this one okay let's see
what we get next uh here's a guy who has
given me plenty of beatings chest friend
90 we play oh here we go just as I say
that we've played many times in the
marathon not the only time let's try
French primarily five Oh games I think
yeah that's what the marathon was that I
did half marathon call it an exchange
French okay let's start with Bishop d6
so that I could play Knight here in
Bishop f5 now let's try this this is a
desirable exchange light-square bishop
ties in well with this guy any ins
let's castle I want to keep this tension
I want them to capture me let's play
rook here mm-hmm and
what about this move I think this is
fine okay you insist I'm going to take
maybe we take again yeah ooh
considering that capture I would weaken
this square I roll up okay
don't know if I'm really playing this
the best hmm let's start with this move
there's nothing really happening on the
queenside well now there is
let's stop that pawn from grabbing any
space Knight b3 I have b6 I'm looking
for Queen here and then queen of five
now this is important because this night
might try to go over there clean is
unprotected so there's no in-between
shots here I have a time edge a knight
on d6 is a fantastic piece same same for
white the corresponding d3 square one
rook off I'm fine I want to make sure I
can maintain my knight here he stops
rook entry King f7 next it was very
tempting for me this was my knee-jerk
reaction but I want to make sure I can
maintain this post for my knight even
though I was saying this is a good
square I want to stay flexible he's a
strong piece on f5 as well
my opponent sees this it's an
interesting move I'm going to take and
who's to say that another Knight cannot
arrive here when he does he'd be
striking at h4 so for starters this move
I think it's fine to do that this is
weak but I don't see this I don't think
they're going to be able to target that
okay so
they're drifting into this square maybe
I should do this move going
for this me
be bitterly maybe I should have waited
for the night to be here because they
could come over to d2 got to keep an eye
on my time here they have a what ten
seconds okay this I like because in the
end I did how I would have an active
rook I think this is a mistake yeah
because now I'm getting to the file
first
there is no rook entry here definitely
taking the knight and now I have the
active rook
that's all this one is coming down to
who has the the more active rook and
clearly it's black this is the more
influential file they're under a minute
now so I'm just looking to strike it
targets the a Ponzi pawn when I win some
material they're going to play rook to
b3 not much I could do about that
let's take here first then here and I'm
threatening this I want to keep some
pounds on okay the King goes forward I
get to take with check I think they
should have come over here this is a
really strong pose for my rook I'm going
to work my King around King here defends
this guy even do this check if they push
this pawn this is now target that's
further away from the king he wants to
be in the center but now he can't be in
the center and defend this target on g3
let's go here you take this guy I get
this guy
no tricky mates he still lives and
actually we could just start pushing
this pawn he's going to soon be one step
away and all these pawns should be
mopped up soon no let's just give a
check I could do that
applying this this was very bad
technique what I'm doing should still be
winning actually I could come over like
this right I don't want to though we're
going to run it like this okay they were
in time pressure that was still a win
but for a second I was just a little bit
concerned all I'm walking a tightrope I
don't want my king even anywhere on the
edge I had a an eye on their clock like
they're going to lose on time never fall
form a a one in those situations as a
long ways off falling for some 81 but I
took the the safe path let's just say
yeah let's try a Sicilian with d6
already we should be five no okay
I can I get this move in I am which
breaks up their pawn duo subjects my
king do a check but I should be able to
get out of it right
one would think okay yeah
this weekend's d4e for collet pomp takes
check I have this move there's some
problems on their dark squares now and
light squares these two squares so big
trouble no yeah but we first take let's
see let's do that first let's
their bishop pair I want some security
over this square before I try to put
additional pressure on d4 this was
bothering me so now that he's secure and
this night is out of play
I could look to function work some of
the dark squares this is actually a very
nice post am i afraid that he'll be out
of play with g4 yeah a little bit so
let's do that instead that's a very
strong night but let's go here I think
this is only temporarily a bad looking
Bishop takes and then push well they
gave up e4 let's jump in now I could
kick him out with f6 and it's tough to
challenge I really feel like giving him
a boo let's do it weakens this diagonal
don't know that I even want to take here
now I don't I'm looking for this move
well maybe no maybe not this stuff b3 I
think should come soon I may allow
double isolated pawns if I could grant
my Queen this square you actually yep I
was just ready to say that is a scary
move hmm okay I have to be very careful
of this square as a whole and already
has support so let's put immediate
pressure on it in my idea here is to
capture with the night so that I could
try to hunt this pawn down so what's
necessary is Knight there they're giving
me that pun for I don't think any good
reason um this seems safer I think I
could have gotten away with Queen takes
as well I didn't see a good forward
Square for the night good forward
discovery so I just want to get rook
here and rook to C or Bishop to ca
but first maybe best to get my night out
of the line of fire I was ready to
retreat but why should I be retreating
here I should be thinking forward this
pond controls this night I think I'm
safe everywhere else
let's go Knight g3 looking at the e4
square no reason not to jump back into
this weak point let's get there you can
even look to Ankara man however I don't
want to be too quick to give this Square
back up let's go rook here have to be
prepared for some sacrifices here they
have a lot of hole boy they have a lot
of firepower there is what I was ready
to say um bit scary yes let's get out of
a capture here with Czech I popped out
I want a bishop for a knight exchange
and then everything is going to be fine
Bishop c8 44 seconds fine with this
definitely fine with this I want to take
with the rook probably Queen e7 look for
some more
Changez I'd like to have one rook off
before I pull this rook away from the F
file okay let's just drop all the way
back I don't want this move to hit with
tempo I want to get my queen other way
so my bishop has direct sight of f5
evening out on time now 35 seconds each
okay that's a good move to see I get
Queen here with tempo oh that's that's
what their idea was there okay I have
this move though I want to get my King
back over here my pawn does a good job
in restricting their Knight now let's
move forward a week in this dark square
but now the knight isn't getting to that
square anytime soon plus they only have
20 seconds there's the clock factor now
as well let's do this I want to keep out
Knight f4 mm not sure what that's about
okay they're just okay they just went a
little nutty there time pressure just
looking to get rid of that night they
just dough through the kitchen sink at
me they rattled off those moves too soon
still a lot of time before those last
seconds were burned 32 is in first 28
I'm four back 32 28 27 hey des he is
currently playing a game yes this is
still live and ooh another tough
opponent let's try D now let's try
Knight f3 how about and d4 c4
change love you boring player you let's
play Knight c3 go with the capture what
capture a for Bishop f5 let's play
something quick let's go for an exchange
o
capturing in that direction still and
why not okay let's pin the knight
symmetrical structure maybe looking to
play on the Queen side these squares are
extremely important I'm like to see a
dark square bishop exchange in my knight
on c5 wouldn't be the first time
wouldn't be the first time in this
tournament a knight on a night would
arrive on c5 and be good he's all the
better if there isn't a bishop around as
I could rely upon the Knights post on c5
for some time I'm looking at a 3b for a
flight square one of the reasons why I
thought it was awkward to see that
capture is because he's a problem piece
let's do a three first and I think b4 is
good just ruling out Knight here
altogether although Knight a7 into b5 is
an idea this may run into a tactic okay
so what's the big idea okay I think this
is now whole and I think I should
immediately drift to that square I have
some concern of this move though don't
think it's working and I think I could
take here and then take on d5 it's messy
though I wanted that exchange this night
isn't okay now he is closer to getting
here so we're both focusing on these
holes I'm going to get there first and
throw the first punch unlike you know
when you
are these two I could take a night out
on c4 with my bishop time for a flight
square how about this this Knight goes
in this direction how about Queen D no I
shouldn't have done this he needs to be
here to watch over this problem that was
silly fortunately it's a static
structure and I have I could afford
these this little time loss thing I want
to get it rid of him right away and
actually this is a winning shot believe
it or not threatening a fork and you
know if the knight moves I have a fork
with the pawn and if they capture I have
a fork kind of lucked out there because
I wasted some time with Bishop b1 and
then back to d3 I also have a time edge
which is nice I might as well preme of
this are they even able to get this
piece back yeah they have a connected
passed pawn which counts for something
but I don't think it should be enough
I'll just be looking to get my F Rock on
the D file are there any better moves in
this position I don't think so
how about clean just kind of zipping out
here I have this square covered this
could be an annoying piece but my knight
is really strong here also let's not get
our queen trapped or anything like that
let's get a flight square not the best
one but I think it's the right one you
know I'd like to have square for my king
let's move forward here I'm covering
their flight square now there they see
my Knight as a strong piece maybe I
don't want to exchange a knight yeah I
should exchange actually and get my rook
working they have a sensitive back rank
rook here Queen f4 I don't know how
great of an inconvenience my queen
really is here
rook d8 I have Queen f4 Queen takes
Queen I have rook takes rook quits check
let's try to get the Queen's off I can
take with the rook I want to keep my
structure as is I'll come back over here
to can test the D file let's just stop
him from even thinking about moving
and my Rick over control some light
squares look for f4 king f2 King III g4
f5 and a clamp down here in position I
could get this moving now that they
don't have pressure or they don't have
defense to this they still can't I think
I want to keep the tension I think the
more files that are that become open the
better off I am
mmm let's take should I have let that
on move they're going to transfer their
rock you know I'm going to look to hunt
down this pond now with my king yeah
here bishops going to go there that a1
King and pawn ending rook takes King
tastes boom boom boom I think it's
winning
I can get to e3 oh it's not winning
miscalculation one on time but that was
bad calculation there I only saw it as
far as King - III hmm with an i and the
clock as well 36 33 32 well I get paired
up with one more opponent maybe we have
a hundred and six players in this one
and that might be the last one with it
being a three oh man we'll see
hmm yeah I really didn't even think
about burrs arcing or any of that so
trying to play some good some good chess
with the three oh time control
yes should have done that that last game
and I don't think I'm going to get
another pairing with less than 30
seconds now this games going on it's the
guy that's in first all wins 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 games in one game shy him and
yeah not going to get paired up less
than 5
okay just barely in confetti land I'll
take it
he had 106 at the end of this one heydo
and two on min 2009 one two snuck in
there with third 106 Ricky remedy right
on my heels fourth okay let's have a
look at everybody who took part in this
one page two three several pages to go
through with this one over there there
were like 25 to start a lot of late
entries and that's going to do it okay
to the 105 of you that took part in this
could games Oh
you